.
Na, ausgeschlafen?
Die Zeit wurde mal wieder umgestellt
und vielleicht erinnert ihr euch:
Vor der letzten Zeitumstellung
im Frühjahr gab's große Diskussionen.
Schon letztes Jahr gab es eine große
EU-Umfrage mit 4,6 Mio. Teilnehmern,
zwei Drittel davon
übrigens aus Deutschland,
und über 80 % hatten
gegen die Zeitumstellung gestimmt.
Dann hieß es: Gut,
schaffen wir die Zeitumstellung ab!
Nur in welcher Zeit
wollen wir dann permanent leben?
Permanente Sommerzeit,
permanente Winterzeit?
EU-Kommissionschef Juncker sprach
sich für permanente Sommerzeit aus,
weil die bei der Umfrage
beliebter war.
Millionen haben geantwortet
und sind der Auffassung,
dass es so sein sollte,
dass die Sommerzeit in Zukunft
für alle Zeit gilt.
Ich werde zuerst
in der Kommission dafür werben,
dass man, wenn man die Bürger fragt,
auch das tun muss,
was die Bürger zum Ausdruck bringen.
Wie sieht ihr das?
Dauerhafte Sommerzeit
oder dauerhafte Winterzeit?
Stimmt hier oben ab.
Wie? Da ist gar keine Umfrage?
Richtig, das ist nämlich
gar keine Meinungsfrage.
Denn wie wir unsere Uhren stellen,
hat echte, biologische Auswirkungen
auf unseren Körper.
Deswegen sollte diese Frage
auch biologisch,
chronobiologisch bewertet werden.
Was die Zeitumstellung
genau mit unserem Körper anstellt
und in welcher Zeit wir permanent
leben sollten, das klären wir jetzt.
* Titelmelodie *
Also, ihr wisst ja,
die Sommerzeit ist die Zeit,
wo wir eine Stunde
früher aufstehen müssen.
Eine Stunde früher als Normalzeit,
sprich Winterzeit.
D.h., die normale Zeit, die galt,
bevor die Zeitumstellung eingeführt
wurde, ist die Winterzeit.
Falls ihr euch schon
mit dem Thema beschäftigt habt,
seid ihr vielleicht über folgende
Expertenmeinungen gestolpert.
Sommerzeit macht uns
"dicker, dümmer, grantiger".
Kann das sein?
Immerhin sprechen wir von nur einer
Stunde Abweichung von der Normalzeit.
Schauen wir uns mal genauer an,
wie unsere innere Uhr
mit der äußeren Uhr zusammenhängt.
Dass wir alle eine innere Uhr haben,
wisst ihr schon aus diesem Video.
Diese innere Uhr ist tatsächlich
in unseren Genen codiert,
die jeden Tag bestimmte Proteine
produzieren, zyklenweise.
Diese Proteine nennen wir der
Einfachheit halber Uhren-Proteine.
Wenn das Uhren-Protein weg ist,
kann das Gen wieder abgelesen werden,
es kann also wieder
neues Protein produzieren
und der ganze Zyklus
fängt wieder von vorne an.
Und das Ganze
dauert eben ungefähr 24 Stunden.
Manche Menschen
sind genetisch bedingte Lerchen.
D.h.: Frühaufsteher
und Früh-zu-Bett-Geher.
Andere Menschen
sind genetisch bedingte Eulen.
D.h.: Spätaufsteher
und Spät-zu-Bett-Geher. Hi!
Lerchen haben eine innere Uhr
bzw. eine innere Tageslänge,
die kürzer ist als 24 Stunden.
Eulen haben eine innere Tageslänge,
die länger ist als 24 Stunden.
- Das ist aber was,
was man nur im Schlaflabor sieht.
Im Alltag ist es bei uns allen so,
dass wir uns
mit dem Tag synchronisieren
und eine Tageslänge
von genau 24 Stunden haben.
- Das ist Lars, unser
hauseigener maiLab-Schlafforscher.
Wie ihr wisst, ist Lars
seit Januar festes Team-Mitglied
und bekannt für bestechende Grafiken
auf seinem Kühlschrank.
- Das hier ist ein Tag
mit Sonnenschein und Dunkelheit.
Und das hier wäre unsere innere Uhr.
Die ist normalerweise
schön synchronisiert,
sodass sie Gas gibt und wir Gas
geben, wenn es hell ist draußen.
Und wenn es dunkel ist,
dann stehen wir auf Ruhezeit.
Wenn wir jetzt nach New York fliegen,
dann ist es da
sechs Stunden früher als bei uns.
D.h., unsere innere Uhr
geht sechs Stunden nach.
Die kriegt aber sofort mit,
dass sie nicht stimmt,
und fängt an, sich anzupassen.
Aber sie schafft nicht
die ganzen sechs Stunden auf einmal,
sondern immer nur einen Teil davon.
Sagen wir mal, damit wir
ein konkretes Beispiel haben,
sie schafft an einem Tag ein Drittel.
D.h., sie würde am ersten Tag
sich um zwei Stunden vorstellen,
geht dann immer noch
vier Stunden nach.
Am nächsten Tag stellt sie sich
wieder ein Drittel vor usw.,
sodass wir
sechs, sieben Tage brauchen,
um bei der New Yorker Ortszeit
anzukommen.
Unsere innere Uhr ist also träge,
sie braucht ein bisschen,
um Veränderungen anzunehmen.
Man kann auch sagen, unsere innere
Uhr ist ein starker Oszillator.
Man muss sie sehr stark anschieben,
um sie nur
so ein bisschen zu verstellen.
Wäre sie ein schwacher Oszillator,
könnte man sie sehr leicht verstellen
und dann gäbe es auch kein Jetlag.
Dann würde sie sich sofort
an die neue Ortszeit anpassen.
Das hört sich erst mal an, als wäre
das knorke, wenn das so wäre.
Aber man muss sich auch überlegen,
dass unsere Evolution
uns ja nicht daran angepasst hat,
in den Urlaub zu fliegen,
sondern dass wir eine stabile,
verlässliche innere Uhr haben.
Die sich z.B. nicht
aus dem Tritt bringen lässt,
wenn es mal nachts einen
Gewitterblitz gibt oder sowas.
Deswegen ist es sehr sinnvoll,
dass unsere innere Uhr ein starker
Oszillator ist, kein schwacher.
Es hat aber Konsequenzen
für unseren Alltag.
Nehmen wir an, ich wäre, wie die
meisten Menschen, eine leichte Eule,
mit einer inneren Tageslänge
von 24 Stunden, 10 Minuten.
Um mich mit dem echten Tag
zu synchronisieren,
der nur 24 Stunden hat, muss ich
meine innere Uhr jeden Tag umstellen.
Und zwar jeden Tag
um 10 Minuten vorstellen.
Schauen wir uns das
am Beispiel mit dem Jetlag an.
Mai ist in New York und
ihre Uhr geht sechs Stunden nach.
Jeden Tag kann die sich
ein Drittel vorstellen.
Dann kommt sie irgendwann an den
Punkt, wo der New Yorker Tagesanfang
genau 30 Minuten vor Mais innerer
Uhr, ihrem inneren Tagesanfang kommt.
Und diese 30 Minuten Unterschied
reichen genau aus,
um die innere Uhr
10 Minuten vorzustellen.
Das wäre jetzt in unserem Beispiel,
mit meiner inneren Tageslänge
von 24 Stunden, 10 Minuten,
eine Punktlandung,
denn damit käme ich auf die
perfekte Tageslänge von 24 Stunden.
D.h., dass sie am nächsten Tag wieder
genau zur gleichen Zeit aufwacht.
Und dann wieder gefühlt der Tag
30 Minuten zu früh anfängt.
Das reicht dann wieder genau,
um die innere Uhr wieder
genau 10 Minuten vorzustellen,
sodass sie wieder genau da rauskommt.
Also sie pendelt sich
bei diesen 30 Minuten zu spät ein.
Oder 30 Minuten später als jemand,
der schon genetisch 24 Stunden Länge
natürlicherweise mitbringen würde.
- Das ist also der Grund, warum Eulen
mit einer längeren inneren Tageslänge
Spätaufsteher sind.
Wäre jetzt meine innere Tageslänge
24 Stunden und 15 Minuten,
würde sich mein innerer Tagesanfang
entsprechend bei 45 Minuten
nach dem tatsächlichen Tagesanfang
einpendeln.
Und das ist der Grund,
warum Eulen und Lerchen
sich in ihren Tagesrhythmen
um Stunden unterscheiden können,
obwohl die Unterschiede
der natürlichen inneren Tageslängen
eher im Minutenbereich sind.
Okay, aber was ist jetzt
dieser "äußere Tag"?
Wonach richtet sich
unsere innere Uhr?
Verschiedene Dinge können
sogenannter Zeitgeber sein.
Das können
regelmäßige Mahlzeiten sein,
regelmäßige Aktivitäten wie Sport.
Aber der stärkste Zeitgeber
ist das Licht.
Und das ist nicht verwunderlich
aus evolutionärer Sicht.
Schließlich ist der tägliche Wechsel
von Hell und Dunkel genau der Grund,
warum wir eine innere Uhr
entwickelt haben.
Bei Licht macht es einen großen
Unterschied, wie hell das Licht ist.
Helles Licht verstellt unsere innere
Uhr viel stärker als schwaches Licht.
In unserem Beispiel sind wir
von Folgendem ausgegangen:
Nämlich wenn das Licht gefühlt
30 Minuten zu früh kommt,
verstellt sich die innere Uhr
um 10 Minuten.
Wenn das Licht aber sehr schwach ist,
muss es vielleicht 45 oder
50 Minuten gefühlt zu früh kommen,
damit sich unsere innere Uhr
um 10 Minuten verstellt.
Für Menschen mit
der üblichen inneren Tageslänge
von etwa 24 Stunden, 10 Minuten heißt
das: Je schwächer euer Zeitgeber ist,
desto später am Tag
pendelt ihr euch ein.
Wenn ihr z.B. den ganzen Tag im Büro
sitzt oder vor dem Schnitt-Rechner,
werdet ihr zu Spätaufstehern. Hi!
Wenn ihr aber dafür
viel helles Tageslicht abbekommt,
pendelt ihr euch wieder näher
am tatsächlichen Tagesbeginn ein.
Den Einfluss des Tageslichts
kann man auch sehen,
wenn wir uns Menschen im Osten
und Westen Deutschlands anschauen.
An unserer Ostgrenze
geht die Sonne nämlich
eine halbe Stunde früher auf
als im Westen.
Und die Menschen im Osten stehen an
freien Tagen von alleine früher auf
als die Menschen im Westen.
Die anderen Sachen,
die wir regelmäßig machen,
also der Wecker,
das Frühstück, die Arbeit,
das sind alles schwache Zeitgeber
im Vergleich zum Licht.
Wenn wir uns nur darauf verlassen,
dann werden moderate Spätaufsteher
schnell zu Eulen.
Anders gesagt, der Wecker bringt mich
zwar morgens aus dem Bett,
aber er reicht nicht aus, um meine
innere Uhr ausreichend umzustellen.
Was jetzt passiert,
nennt sich "sozialer Jetlag".
Ähnlich wie beim echten Jetlag
ist unsere innere Uhr
gegenüber der Tageszeit verschoben.
Deswegen gehen wir dann zur Arbeit,
zur Schule zu einer Tageszeit,
wo eigentlich unsere innere Uhr
noch auf Schlaf steht.
Abends steht sie
noch nicht auf Schlaf,
wenn es eigentlich
Schlafenszeit ist.
Deswegen schlafen wir nicht ein
und schlafen jede Nacht zu kurz,
weil der Wecker uns ja
morgens wieder rausschmeißt.
Dadurch häuft sich dann Tag für Tag
ein Schlafdefizit an.
- Und wie ungesund Schlafmangel ist,
haben wir schon
in diesem Video erklärt.
Und der soziale Jetlag korreliert
mit verschiedenen Problemen.
Und zwar genau die, die man erwartet,
wenn jemand
chronischen Schlafmangel hat.
Z.B. Übergewicht
mit erhöhtem Risiko für Diabetes,
Stimmungsschwankungen,
natürlich eingeschränkte
geistige Leistungsfähigkeit,
denn man ist nicht so wach.
- Daher kommt also die Schlagzeile
"Dicker, dümmer, grantiger".
Denn es ist davon auszugehen,
dass solche Probleme zunehmen werden.
Deswegen raten Chronobiologen
von einer ganzjährigen Sommerzeit ab.
Permanente Sommerzeit würde bedeuten,
dass all die Menschen,
die jetzt schon
unter sozialem Jetlag leiden,
dann noch eine Stunde
früher aufstehen müssten.
Und das Tageslicht
wird ihnen nicht dabei helfen,
denn das Tageslicht bleibt so,
wie es ist.
Wir entfernen uns
nur mit unserem Alltag
weiter von unserer inneren Uhr.
Im Winter würde uns die Sommerzeit
besonders zu schaffen machen,
denn im Winter
haben wir kürzer Tageslicht.
Es ist auch
nicht so hell wie im Sommer.
Und wir kriegen davon
auch nicht so viel ab,
weil wir nicht so viel rausgehen.
D.h., im Winter
ist der Zeitgeber viel schwächer.
Das hieße für die meisten von uns,
dass wir
stärkere Spätaufsteher werden.
Aber was ist mit den Lerchen,
mit den Frühaufstehern?
Wäre es für die
nicht andersrum ungerecht?
Mache ich hier nur Eulen-Lobbyarbeit?
Also erst mal: Eulen und Lerchen,
das sind nur die Extreme.
Die meisten von uns
sind irgendwo dazwischen.
Aber ein Großteil der Bevölkerung
ist eher auf der euligen Seite.
D.h., es gibt mehr Leute, die diese
Probleme haben mit dem Frühaufstehen.
Aber davon abgesehen
ist ein viel wichtigerer Punkt,
wie unser Alltag
normalerweise aufgebaut ist.
Normalerweise ist morgens die Arbeit
und abends die Freizeit.
D.h., für Lerchen
ist es im Normalfall,
wenn sie abends schon früh müde sind,
viel leichter zu sagen:
Sorry, ich lass die Party heute
ausfallen, ich bin zu müde.
Für Eulen ist das meistens
ein bisschen schwieriger.
Sorry, Chef,
ich schlaf morgen 'ne Stunde länger,
sonst bin ich immer so müde.
Verstehen Sie, oder?
Deswegen kommt es bei Lerchen
auch deutlich seltener vor,
dass sie gegen ihre innere Uhr leben.
Weniger als 2 %
der untersuchten Menschen
haben einen negativen
sozialen Jetlag,
sodass sie abends noch unter
der Woche regelmäßig aktiv sind,
und eigentlich die innere Uhr
schon auf Schlafengehen steht.
Über die Hälfte der Leute
haben einen sozialen Jetlag
in die andere Richtung
von einer Stunde oder mehr.
D.h., sie müssen
regelmäßig morgens raus,
obwohl ihr Körper eigentlich
noch nicht bereit dazu ist.
Klar kann man dagegen steuern
mit Maßnahmen wie:
regelmäßig rausgehen ans Tageslicht,
zu Hause eine Tageslichtlampe
benutzen und abends darauf achten,
dass man nicht mehr
auf helle Bildschirme kuckt.
Aber d.h. kämpfen, darum kämpfen,
dass unsere innere Uhr schön
mit dem Tag synchronisiert ist.
Und mit der Sommerzeit
müssen wir einfach stärker kämpfen.
Das ist schwieriger
als mit der Winterzeit.
Jetzt sagen manche vielleicht, wenn
ich abends länger Tageslicht habe,
und dadurch mehr
Freizeitmöglichkeiten,
dann ist mir dieser Zugewinn
an Lebensqualität
eventuelle
gesundheitliche Nachteile wert.
Das ist prinzipiell
kein schlechtes Argument.
Nur um eine gute Entscheidung
treffen zu können, müssen wir
die gesundheitlichen Konsequenzen
1) natürlich akzeptieren,
und 2) so genau wie möglich kennen,
um eine vernünftige Abwägung
zu machen.
Und hier muss man tatsächlich
festhalten, wie dick, dumm, traurig
wir durch permanente Sommerzeit
werden würden,
ist derzeit noch nicht klar.
Wir wissen derzeit auf jeden Fall,
es würde in eine
unvorteilhafte Richtung gehen.
Wie stark der Effekt ist, das müsste
man mit empirischer Forschung messen.
Das Tückische an falschem
Schlafrhythmus und Schlafmangel ist,
dass sich die Folgen schleichend
und langfristig einstellen.
D.h., man merkt nicht so schnell,
wenn man sich selbst durch
einen ungesunden Lebensstil schadet.
Bis wir diesen Schaden
genauer beziffern können,
gibt es jetzt schon Erkenntnisse
aus der Chronobiologie,
die uns im Alltag
sehr viel helfen könnten.
Z.B. weg von dieser Denke
"Der frühe Vogel fängt den Wurm"
in unserer Arbeitswelt.
Nein, wir sollten überall, wo
es nur geht, Gleitzeit einführen,
damit alle Chrono-Typen
von Eulen bis Lerchen
im Einklang mit ihrem biologischen
Rhythmus arbeiten können.
Oder spätere Schulzeiten
in weiterführenden Schulen,
weil gerade Jugendliche einen
besonders späten Rhythmus haben.
Darum ging's
in unserem letzten Video.
Selbst für die Schichtarbeit
gibt es chronobiologische Konzepte,
die sie verträglicher machen könnte.
Doch all diese Ratschläge
der Chronobiologen
werden seit Jahren ignoriert. Hm!
Insofern bin ich froh, dass diese
Entscheidung zur Zeitumstellung
nicht auf Basis irgendwelcher
Umfragen getroffen wurde,
sondern dass die Entscheidung
erst mal vertagt wurde
auf voraussichtlich 2021.
Und ich kann nur hoffen,
dass bis dahin klar wird,
dass es sich hier nicht
um eine Meinungsfrage handelt,
sondern um eine medizinische.
Wenn ihr das Video bis hierhin
gesehen habt, gehe ich davon aus,
dass euch das Thema interessiert.
Deswegen hier zwei Videos für euch,
falls ihr sie
noch nicht gesehen habt.
Einmal unser letztes Video
zur inneren Uhr,
das habe ich heute
schon ein paarmal zitiert.
Und mein Quarks-Experiment,
wo ich meine persönliche innere Uhr
habe bestimmen lassen
durch einen Bluttest.
Wir sehen uns bald,
bis dahin bleibt sicher!
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von funk (2019)